ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD CARRIER [inaudible]
CHIANG.
THE RISE OF GALGIANI
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO --
TITLE JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN AND PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT
OUR MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE REAL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LET IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BURKE CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING IT WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I SENATOR
ROTH [inaudible]
YOU.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
THE POET KAHLIL GIBRAN'S SAYS.
LET THESE BE YOUR DESIRES. TO
WAKE AT DAWN WITH A WINGED HEART.
AND GIVE THANKS FOR ANOTHER DAY
OF LOVING.
GRACIOUS AND LOVING GODS.
AS WE BEGIN THIS DAY.
HELP US TO BE GRATEFUL FOR THE
POSSIBILITIES AND HOLDS.
GIVE WINGS TO OUR HEARTS.
ENABLING US TO SOAR ABOVE THE
LIMITATIONS OF YESTERDAY DE
YESTER YEARS CHALLENGES.
LIBERATE OUR HEARTS TO ATTEMPT
THE SEEMINGLY IMPOSSIBLE TASKS
WITH DESIRE TO ACCOMPLISH.
AND SO OFTEN ARE HARD. TO LOVE
EVEN THE DISRUPTIVE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT DALY PRESENT
THEMSELVES.
LESS ARE WINGED HEARTS FLOOR IN
WAVES OF GRAITUDE. FOR ALL THAT
IS A MAN [inaudible]
HI OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE
NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE FIRST
ANNOUNCEMENT IS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO WISH SENATOR BRADFORD A
VERY VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY SENATOR
BRADFORD.
SENATOR HERTZBERG WHAT PURPOSE
YOU RISE.
AND I LIKE TO ADD THE A MADAM
PRESIDENT THAT --
AFTER SESSION THERE IS A VERY
LARGE CELEBRATING CENTER BRAD
RICHARDS --
BIRTHDAYS IN ROOM TWO OH FIVE
NINE HAPPY BIRTHDAY SIR.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG HAPPY BIRTHDAY SENATOR
BRADFORD MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES.
I RISE THIS MORNING.
IN SOLEMN REMEMBRANCE OF THE
DEBRIS FLOW THAT OCCURRED.
JUST ONE YEAR AGO YESTERDAY.
IN MY DISTRICT ACTUALLY IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN MONESSEN JACKSON ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
WE GET EVERYONE'S ATTENTION
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES.
ARE A ONE YEAR AGO.
YESTERDAY.
TWENTY THREE A FRIENDS.
ASSOCIATES COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
CONSTITUENTS.
DIED IN A DEBRIS FLOW OF THAT
WAS CAUSED BY WHAT WAS AT THE
TIME THE LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
THESE WERE TWENTY THREE INNOCENT
PEOPLE RANGING IN AGE FROM. TO
TO NINETY TWO LITERALLY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT WERE SWEPT
OUT OF THEIR HOMES.
AS A RESULT OF A FIRE.
THAT HAD OCCURRED JUST TWO WEEKS
PREVIOUSLY.
AND HAD BURNED THE HILLSIDE
ABOVE THIS COMMUNITY.
AND SUDDENLY WITHOUT ANY
EXPECTATION A OF SELF A RAIN
CELLS.
SPENT FIVE MINUTES OVER THE HILL
SIDE OF THIS COMMUNITY POURING
HALF AN INCH OF RAIN.
IN FIVE MINUTES.
AND AS A RESULT LITERALLY THE
MOUNTAIN CAME DOWN.
THERE WERE BOULDERS OF IMMENSE
MAGNITUDE AND WAIT THAT WERE
LITERALLY LIKE SPONGEBOB'S
BOBBING DOWN.
A THIRTY MILE AN HOUR RIVER.
IT HAD BEEN CREATED.
AND WE LOST.
SOME OF OUR MOST HIGHLY
RESPECTED.
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY DOCTORS
PLAN TO PASS [inaudible]
CHILDREN.
I IT HAS BEEN A TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE THAT.
LIVES WITH US ON A DAILY BASIS
IN FACT JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO
WHEN WE HAD OUR FIRST RAIN OF
THE YEAR I WAS TALKING.
TO SEVERAL OF MY FRIENDS WHO
ADMITTED THAT THEY HEARD THE
RAIN STARTED TWO O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING.
AND THEY COULD GO BACK TO SLEEP.
THIS KIND OF TRAUMA CONTINUES.
NACHOS FOR THE PEOPLE OF MY
DISTRICT.
BUT A FEW MONTHS PRIOR TO THE
THOMAS FIRE WE HAD THE FIRES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH KILLED OVER FORTY PEOPLE.
SINCE THEN WE HAD THE CAMPFIRE
AND THE WHEELS HE FIRE.
SO IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT.
THERE ARE VERY FEW OF US WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN PERSONALLY
IMPACTED.
BY THESE FIRES.
AND I WOULD JUST ASK US TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO REFLECT.
ON THE LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN LOST
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT AND
THROUGHOUT OUR BELOVED STATE.
AND THANK OF AN BROWN AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR RECOGNIZE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE.
BEEN DEALING WITH NATURE.
AT CASTING HER FURY UPON US.
AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE STILL
VERY MUCH AT RISK IN ALL PARTS
OF THE STATE.
IN AREAS WHERE THERE HAD BEEN
THESE SEVERE BURNS ARE STILL
POTENTIALLY SUBJECT. TO
MUDSLIDES AND DEBRIS FLOWS.
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
YEARS OF DROUGHT.
WE ARE NOW SEEING A LOT OF RAIN.
RAIN CAN BE AS MISCHIEVOUS.
AS FIRES.
AND CERTAINLY AFTER THOSE FIRES
PROTECTS THESE HILLSIDES AND THE
BEAUTIFUL AREAS IN WHICH WE WE
LIVE BECAUSE THIS IS CALIFORNIA
THERE IS NO PLACE MORE BEAUTIFUL.
BUT WE ARE REALIZING THAT THERE
IS ALSO.
NO PLACE RIGHT NOW THAT COULD BE
MORE DANGEROUS AND SO I WOULD
ASK US ALL TO JUST REMEMBER.
MY TWENTY THREE CONSTITUENTS AND
FRIENDS.
THE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE IN THE
THOUSANDS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES IN WHOSE LIVES HAVE BEEN.
IRREPARABLY DAMAGED.
THE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAS OCCURRED
AND WILL LIKELY CONTINUE TO KERR.
OCCUR AND THAT WE ALL WE COMMIT
TO DOING WHAT WE CAN TO PROTECT.
OUR CONSTITUENTS THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND KNOWS WHOSE LIVES
HAVE BEEN LOST IN THESE
TRAGEDIES.
THAT COMMAND PRESS THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON'S MEMBERS ANY
ADDITIONAL AND TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NORTON
NOTICES INTRODUCTIONS AND FIRST
READINGS OF BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND THIS
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR ADJOURNED IN MEMORIES.
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
OUR COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY --
TO ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN THE
SENATE IN MEMORY OF WES --
ROMIJN.
OUT WEST'S ARE WITH A PERSONAL
FRIEND OF MINE.
A PASSED AWAY ON NOVEMBER
TWENTIETH IN SAN FRANCISCO --
FOLLOWING A VALIANT FOUR YEAR
BATTLE AGAINST CANCER --
HE IED WITH HIS FAMILY AND MANY
FRIENDS THAT ASIDE --
HE WAS FORTY EIGHT YEARS OLD.
BUT WHAT'S HIS DEATH WAS A
PERSONAL FOR ME AND FOR MANY
PEOPLE.
IN MY COMMUNITY HE WAS A FRIEND
TO SO MANY OF US.
IT WAS ONE OF THE KINDEST MOST
OUTGOING --
MOST THOUGHTFUL PEOPLE I'VE EVER
KNOWN SOMEONE WITH INTERNET.
POSITIVE ENERGY.
HE WAS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
EVERYONE KNEW --
THAT EVERYONE LIGHTS.
AND THAT EVERYONE WANTED TO
SPEND TIME WITH.
OUT WEST HAD A HUGE HEART A
PASSION FOR LIFE --
AND HE UNAPOLOGETICALLY LIVES
HIS LIFE OUT LOUD.
HE ENJOYED TRAVEL SPENDING TIME
WITH HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
IF YOU ASKED ANYONE TO DESCRIBE
WEST THEY WERE UNIVERSALLY USE
WORDS LIKE GENTLE CRIMES
SELFLESS CAREFREE.
ARE HE LOVED HELPING PEOPLE AND
HE LOVES CONNECTING PEOPLE TO
EACH OTHER.
HE LAUGHED A LOT HE WAS ALWAYS
HAVING FUN ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
WHO YOU CAN NEVER GET HIM DOWN --
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENED IN HIS
LIFE.
AND YOU ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OTHER PEOPLE WERE HAVING
FUN.
IT WAS HARD NOT TO BE HAPPY AND
NOT TO SMILE WHEN YOU'RE AROUND
WES.
I AFTER WEST WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER FOUR YEARS AGO HE'D
INSIST CURL UP INTO A BALL LIKE
MANY OF US MIGHT BE TEMPTED TO
DO.
AND HIS TYPICAL WESTSIDE ALL.
HE MADE THE VERY BEST OF A BAD
SITUATION --
HE FOUGHT HIS CANCER LIKE CRAZY
HE WON SUPPOSED TO LIVE FOR FOUR
YEARS NEEDED.
HE MADE CLEAR THAT IF THE CANCER
WAS GOING TO TAKE HIM IT WASN'T
GOING TO HAPPEN WITHOUT A FIGHT.
HE POSTED IT MANY MANY UPDATES
ON FACEBOOK ABOUT HIS DIAGNOSIS
HIS TREATMENT AND IS PROGRESS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LEARNS.
ABOUT THE REALITY OF CANCER
TREATMENT.
BECAUSE OF WEST HIS OPENNESS
ABOUT HIS HEALTH CONDITION.
WES UNFORTUNATELY SPENT A LOT OF
TIME GOING IN AND OT OF THE
HOSPITAL OVER THE YEARS AND ALSO
IN TYPICAL WEST STYLE.
HIS HOSPITAL ROOM WAS PRETTY
MUCH PERMANENTLY FILLED WITH
VISITORS.
IN OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES YOU MIGHT
FEEL BAD FOR THE HOSPITAL STAFF
HAVING TO DEAL WITH ALL THESE
CROWDS.
AND SO MANY VISITORS BUT NOT
WITH WES BECAUSE IN TYPICAL WEST
STYLE.
THE HOSPITAL STAFF WOULD QUICKLY
BECOME HIS FRIENDS AND BOND WITH
HIM.
WESSEL BORN IN RED BLUFF
CALIFORNIA TO PARENTS JOHN AND
NORMA.
HE WAS THE YOUNGEST OF FIVE
CHILDREN.
HE ATTENDED ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
MADERA AND GRADUATED FROM MADERA
HIGH IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAJOR
MARKETING AND GRADUATED FROM CAL
STATE FRESNO AND NINETEEN NINETY
THREE HE HAD A SUCCESSFUL CAREER
IN BANKING CUSTOMER SERVICE
SALES AND MARKETING.
I SPENT THE LATTER PART OF HIS
CAREER WERE WORKING FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BASED MARKETING
COMPANY NINETY NINE DESIGNS.
HE WAS AN UNOFFICIAL AMBASSADOR
FOR SAN FRANCISCO.
HE WOULD STOP TO TALK TO
TOURISTS WHO LOOKED LOST.
HE WOULD NOT ONLY POINT THEM IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTIONS BUT HE
WOULD SOMETIMES START SHOWING
THEM AROUND TAKE THEM ON A
WALKING TOUR.
HE MADE FRIENDS WITH THESE
PEOPLE I WOULD STAY IN TOUCH
WITH THEM AFTERWARDS.
OUT WEST WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH
BY HIS FATHER JOHN AND HIS
SISTER CRISTINA.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER
NORMA HIS BROTHER'S CARLAND GIO
HIS SISTER CONNIE --
AND HIS BEST FRIENDS JASON DORN.
WEST WE LOVE YOU REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER YOUR
ANOTHER ATTORNEY MEMBER THAT YOU
WANTED TO DO.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
ARE COLLEAGUES --
IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
RIGHTS TO US THAT WE TURN ST THE
FATHER --
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM --
JUDGE NEWSOM WAS BORN ON
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR IN SAN FRANCISCO --
AND LIVE THERE --
THROUGHOUT THE BOOK OF HIS LIFE.
HE ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO STUDYING FRENCH
LITERATURE FOR HIS MASTER'S
DEGREE AND LATER ATTENDED LAW
SCHOOL AT STANFORD.
WALSER EARNING A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN ENGLISH LITERATURE.
SHIFTING FROM HIS ORIGINAL GOAL
TO BE AN ENGLISH TEACHER --
JUDGE KNEW SOME TOOK A JOB THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT --
AFTER COLLEGE IN ORDER TO PURSUE --
LEGAL CAREER --
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN AFTER
SPENDING A FEW YEARS ABROAD HE
RETURNED TO SAN FRANCISCO TO RUN
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS --
WHEN THAT DID NOT GO EXACTLY AS
HE PLANS --
HE MOVED TO SQUAW VALLEY AND
OPEN THE SOLO LAW PRACTICE AND
TALK WITH CITY.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE UGH THE
GOVERNOR BROWN --
IN ITS FIRST RUN APPOINTED --
JUDGE NEW SOME TO A PLASTER
COUNTY SUPERIOR --
AND THEN THREE YEARS LATER HE
APPOINTED HIM TO THE COURT OF
APPEALS --
HE WAS ONLY --
FORTY FOUR AT THAT AT THE TIME
OF THAT APPOINTMENT.
I JUDGE YOU SOME WAS AN ADVOCATE
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
SERVED ON THE BOARDS OF THE
SIERRA CLUB FOUNDATION.
EARTH JUSTICE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND --
HE ALSO HELPED FOUND THE
MOUNTAIN LION PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION.
I JUDGES SOME IS SURVIVED BY HIS
SON GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM AND
HIS DAUGHTER HILLARY KNEW SOME
TALENT --
WHOM JUDGE NEW SOME TALK CAMPING
AND BACKPACKING ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS DURING THEIR
CHILDHOOD SUMMERS.
HE HAS SIX GRANDCHILDREN PLEASE
JOIN ME AND ADJOURNING TODAY'S
SENATE SUCH AN IN MEMORY OF
JUDGE WILLIAM NEWSOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER CENTER
DAUGHTER JEWISH TO SPEAK ON THIS.
SINCE THE ADAM BENNETT PRESIDENT --
I'D LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS A
JOURNEY MEMORY FOR JUSTICE
NEWSOME WITHOUT COUNTY
SUPERVISOR NAPA JUST SAID
NEWSOME --
AS MAYBE YOU MIGHT KNOW HAD
BUSINESS INTEREST --
IN THE NAPA VALLEY AND CAME TO
NAPA -- TO
GO TO LUNCH WITH A COUPLE TIMES
TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT WERE
IMPORTANT --
TO NAPA COUNTY HE ACTUALLY WAS
THE THE JUSTICE THAT --
WHEN THE --
Y. REDEFINITION ORDINANCE WHICH
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO KEEP
BEING THAT SETS A PLACE IN NAPA
WAS.
APPEALED --
HE STOOD IN SUPPORT.
OF IT IN FAVOR OF AND NAPA AND
THAT'S SLOW GROWTH --
MENTALITY I THINK THAT IS MADE
IT -- OTHER
GREAT PLACE IT IS AND HE HAD A
GREAT --
DEAL TO DO WITHOUT BY HIS
DECISION --
I REALLY FOUND HIM TO BE --
OBVIOUSLY A SCHOLAR IN A GENTLE
MAN AND I STAND --
IN SUPPORT OF THIS A JOURNEY
MEMORY THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE AN INTERNAL MEMORY
YES MADAM PRESIDENT SEED SO MUCH
HIGHER WE'VE WE LOST A LARGE
COUNTY NATIVE IN LEGEND.
IN VICTOR A. VICTIME.
WAS BORN ON JUNE FOURTEENTH
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE AND PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY AT HOME ON
NOVEMBER SECOND. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IN ORANGE CALIFORNIA AT THE AGE
OF NINETY SEVEN VIC WAS BORN IN
ORANGE ON JUNE FOURTEENTH.
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE TO CARL --
HIME AND EMMA GROW TIME ONE OF
SIX CHILDREN HE WAS THE LAST OF
THE SIBLINGS TO PASS AWAY.
A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF ORANGE
SHE ATTENDED ST PAUL'S LUTHERAN
SCHOOL ORANGE UNION HIGH SCHOOL
AND GRADUATED FROM SANTA COLLEGE
IN.
NINETEEN FORTY ONE HE ENLISTED
IN THE ARMY AIR CORPS IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO AND SERVED.
EXCUSE ME SERVE AT THE SANTA ANA
ARMY AIR STATION FOR THREE YEARS.
WHICH IS NOW THE LOCATION OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS.
WHILE SERVING AT THE AIR STATION
HE MET THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE.
HAPPY ELIZABETH OR BETTY DRIGO
OF HUNTINGTON BEACH THEY MARRIED
IN JANUARY.
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE IN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN BIG JOINED THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AS A CLERK.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
APPOINTED HIM COUNTY AUDITOR.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HE RAN
AND WON ELECTION TO THE POSITION
AND THEREAFTER RAN UNOPPOSED FOR
THE NEXT SIX FOUR YEAR ELECTION
CYCLES HE RETIRED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AFTER SERVING AS
AUDITOR CONTROLLER FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS.
AND SERVING THE COUNTY FOR A
TOTAL OF THIRTY SEVEN YEARS
GREAT HUMILITY AND INTEGRITY.
BUT WHEN ASKED HOW HE SERVED SO
SUCCESSFULLY FOR SO MANY YEARS
HE ALWAYS GAVE CREDIT TO THE
MANY PEOPLE WHO FAITHFULLY
WORKED ALONGSIDE HIM.
BIG DEEPLY LOVED HIS FAMILY HIS
FRIENDS AND HIS CHURCH HE WAS A
LIFELONG MEMBER OF ST PAUL'S
LUTHERAN CHURCH.
BASICALLY TEACHING SUNDAY SCHOOL
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS AND
SERVING AS THE SECRETARY OF THE
CONGREGATION FOR FIFTY YEARS.
HE WOULD VISIT ME ON OCCASION
AFTER I WAS APPOINTED COUNTY
TREASURER TAX COLLECTOR IN THE
MID NINETIES AND GIVE ME A AN
ATTA BOY WOULD HAVE SOME FUN
CONVERSATION SO IT IS AN HONOR.
TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF SUCH A
DEVOTED ORANGE COUNTY PUBLIC
SERVANT.
AND SHARE THE LAS WITH HIS
LOVING FAMILY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MORLOCK.
CENTER CABALLERO TO GERMAN A
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS TODAY I RISE TO ASKED
WE ATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF AN
AMERICAN HERO AND A CALIFORNIA
HERO.
CORPORAL RENEWAL SAYING A SEVEN
YEAR VETERAN OF THE NEWMAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT WHO LOST HIS
LIFE IN THE LINE OF DUTY DUTY IN
THE EARLY MORNING HOURS OF
DECEMBER TWENTY SIXTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CORPORAL
SAYING WAS ON CONTROL WHEN HE
WAS FLAGGED DOWN BY A CONCERNED
CITIZEN WHO SAW AN OBVIOUSLY
INTOXICATED COST CUSTOMER DRIVE
AWAY FROM A BUSINESS
ESTABLISHMENT.
CORPORAL SING FOLLOW THE
SUSPECTED IMPAIRED DRIVER PULLED
HIM OVER AND IN THE PROCESS OF
CONTACT CONTACTING THE DRIVER
WAS SHOT AND KILLED.
THE SUSPECT FLED THE SCENE WAS
ARRESTED DAYS LATER ALONG WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO WERE
ATTEMPTING TO ASSIST THE SUSPECT
TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
CORPORAL REYNOLDS SAYING WAS
BORN ON THE ISLAND ON THE ISLAND
NATION OF FIJI WHERE HE SPENT
HIS EARLY YEARS SWIMMING AND
FISHING WITH HIS BROTHER REGGIE.
AS  YOUNG TEEN RENAULT BECAME A
FAN OF THE TV SHOW COPS.
AND THERE AND THEN STARTED TO
DREAM ABOUT BECOMING A POLICE
OFFICER AND MOVING TO THE UNITED
STATES.
RENDELL THING IMMIGRATED TO
CALIFORNIA IT'S AND BROTHER AND
SETTLED IN STANISLAUS COUNTY IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE WHERE HE
STUDIED CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
AND AT MODESTO CAN A JUNIOR
COLLEGE AND VOLUNTEERED WITH THE
MODESTO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
CORPORAL SAYING ATTENDED THE
POLICE ACADEMY AND FULFILL HIS
DREAMS OF BECOMING A POLICE
OFFICER AND SERVING HIS FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS WHEN HE BEGAN HIS
CAREER AS A CADET WITH THE
TURLOCK POLICEMEN.
POLICE DEPARTMENT FROM THERE HE
WENT TO WORK AS A RESERVE
OFFICER WITH THE MERCED COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN CORPORAL
SAYING WAS HIRED BY THE SMALL
RURAL CITY OF NEWMAN AND JOIN
THE TIGHTLY KNIT NEWMAN POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
VERY BECAME ONE OF THIRTEEN
SWORN OFFICERS DEDICATED TO
PREVENTING CRIME AND JUSTICE
ENFORCING THE LAW FAIRLY AND
DEFENDING THE RIGHTS OF CITIZENS
DUTIES THAT SPOKE TO CORPORAL
SINGS INNATE DESIRE TO DO GOOD
IN THE WORLD.
A TRAINED CANINE OFFICER
FREQUENTLY ACCOMPANIED
ACCOMPANIED BY HIS CANINE
PARTNER SAM CORPORAL SING
POSSESSED AN ADVENTUROUS SPIRIT
AND PROVIDED AN ADMIRABLE ROLE
MODEL FOR THE YOUTH IN THEIR IN
HIS COMMUNITY.
AT HIS FUNERAL HIS FELLOW
OFFICERS DESCRIBED HIM AS A
DEDICATED POLICE OFFICER AND
TRAINING OFFICER WHO ALWAYS HAD
A SMILE ON HIS FACE AND A
POSITIVE ATTITUDE.
HE WAS A JOKESTER WHO LIKE TO
MAKE WORK FINE AND HAD A LOVE OF
LIFE AND WAS RIVER AS A BROTHER.
HIS LIFE WAS DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF HIS FELLOW CALIFORNIANS
AND WAS CONCERNED ABOUT HELPING
THOSE LESS FORTUNATE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
OFTEN TAKING SUPPLIES AND
CLOTHING TO FAMILIES IN NEED.
HE IS REMEMBERED FOR HIS
FRIENDLY NATURE AND SELFLESS THE
SELFLESS DEVOTION TO HIS FAMILY.
COMMUNITY AND POLICE OFFICERS
FELLOW POLICE OFFICERS ALIKE.
KARPAL SINGH WAS THIRTY THREE
YEARS OLD.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING
WIFE ON TO MAKE THAT CHANCE SING
AND HIS FIVE MONTH OLD SON.
ARE NOW SAYING HIS MOTHER AND
FATHER ROHINI AND THEY'RE SAYING
A BROTHER RATIONALE SAYING HIS
GRANDMOTHER'S ENTIRE WHAT HE'S
SAYING AND HIS IN LAWS --
MASH AND LALITA TRIED AS WELL AS
X. -- G..
ESTEEM AND ABOUT PUBLIC SERVANT
CORPORAL SING WAS AN AMAZING
ROLE MODEL FOR HIS FELLOW
OFFICERS AND THE SMALL COMMUNITY
HE WILL BE SORELY MISSED AND HIS
LEGACY WILL LIVE FOREVER.
MAY CORPORAL SAYING REST IN
PEACE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
CENTER CABALLERO [inaudible]
CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM MODESTO
TO RISE IN ENSURING A MEMORY OF
POLICE AND A NEWMAN POLICE
OFFICER CORPS PERENNIAL SING.
A WHO WAS KILLED N THE LINE OF
DUTY JUST THIS PAST CHRISTMAS.
MANY OF US HAVE SEEN PICTURES OF
OFFICER SINGING AS WIFE MICAH
THEIR NEWBORN SON AND THEIR DOG
SNUGGLE TOGETHER UNDER A
CHRISTMAS TREE.
NO INJURING THAT THIS PICTURE
WHATEVER BE THE LAST ONE TAKEN
TOGETHER AS A FAMILY.
NO ONE KNEW IT WOULD BE THEIR
FINAL MOMENTS MOMENTS THAT THEY
WOULD SHARE TOGETHER WHILE
CONDUCTING A ROUTINE TRAFFIC
STOP OFFERS THIS THING WAS SHOT
AND KILLED.
OFFICER SING WAS A SELFLESS
COMPASSIONATE DEDICATED
HARDWORKING PATRIOT AND HE WAS
THIRTY THREE YEARS OLD.
BORN IN A SMALL TOWN FARMING
TOWN IN FIJI HE IMMIGRATED TO
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE SINCE HE WAS A CHILD FOR
NEIL DREAMED OF BEING A POLICE
OFFICER SO AFTER EARNING HIS U.
S. CITIZENSHIP HE BEGAN A CAREER
WITH THE MODESTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE HE DIDN'T.
SERVE AS A CADET IN THE TURLOCK
POLICE SERVE DEPUTY AND MERCED
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY AROSE. FOR HIM TO
JOIN THE TWELVE MEMBER POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN THE CANINE UNIT IN
NEWMAN CALIFORNIA.
GOING BACK TO CHRISTMAS NIGHT
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO THING WAS
NOTIFIED OF A POSSIBLE DRUNK
DRIVING SITUATION.
HE LOCATED THE VEHICLE HE
RADIOED IN ANY APPROACH THE
VEHICLE.
THE NEXT CALL OVER THE SMALL
NEWMAN POLICE RADIO WERE SHOTS
FIRED OFFICER DOWN.
WHEN HIS BACKUP ARRIVED IN THE
TRANSPORT OFFICER SING TO THE
HOSPITAL WHERE HE WAS PRONOUNCED
DEAD ON ARRIVAL?
AN ALL OUT MAN HUNT WAS DEPLOYED
ICE AGENTS IN SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
SEVERAL LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
A FEW DAYS LATER THE SUSPECTED
KILLER WAS CAPTURED IN MY
COMMUNITY A SMALL.
TOWN IN KERN COUNTY.
I HAD THE HONOR OF ATTENDING
OFFICER SINGS MEMORIAL SERVICE
ALONG WITH MANY COLLEAGUES HERE
ON THE FLOOR.
AND WE LISTENED.
TO SOME OF BRING DEALS.
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS AND
FAMILY SPEAK ABOUT HIS HEART AND
PASSION FOR POLICE WORK
PROTECTING AND SERVING OTHERS.
BUT I PARTICULARLY RECALL A
STORY ABOUT --
HIS GRANDFATHER'S CLOSE HIS
GRANDFATHER HAD PASSED AWAY AND
HE IMMEDIATELY WENT OVER AND GOT
ALL OF HIS CLOTHES AND WENT ON A
TRIP TO MEXICO.
WHEN HE GOT TO MEXICO THAT DAY
HE HANDED OUT ALL THESE CLOTHES
OF HIS GRANDFATHER?
THE NEXT MORNING HIS BROTHER
JOKED THAT WHEN THEY WOKE UP
THEY SAW TWENTY TO THIRTY PEOPLE
INCLUDING OLDER WOMEN WALKING
DOWN THE STREET WEARING HIS
GRANDFATHER'S CLOTHES.
THIS MAN WAS A PROUD AMERICAN
AND EVEN A PROUDER CALIFORNIANS
HE LIVED HIS DREAM PROTECTING
INFANT IN DEFENDING OTHERS HIS
WIFE MICAH HAD LOST THE MAN HE A
SHE LOVES.
THE HIS BABY BOY LOS THE MAN
THAT HE WOULD SOON CALL DAD IN
THE COMMUNITY OF NEW NEWMAN AND
OUR STATE IN THE NATION HAS LOST
A HERO.
WILL BE FOREVER IN DEBT FOR
OFFICER SING SACRIFICE IN HIS
HEART FOR OTHERS IN MY PRAYERS
GO OUT TO HIS FAMILY.
HIS SHORT LIVED LIFE WAS
CELEBRATED JUNE SEE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE AND EVEN DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES CAME TO HONOR THIS
FOLLOWING OFFICER.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ENTER IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE THIRTY
GALGIANI.
I TO RISE TO JOHN IN MEMORY OF
CORPORAL SAYING AND AS IS
SENATOR GROVE MENTIONED WE WERE
JOINED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WE HAVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FROM.
NEW YORK CANADA AND MANY STATES
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S AN AND UNFORTUNATE REMINDER
OF THE DANGERS OF SERVING IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WE KNOW THAT
EVERY TIME A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER LEAVES THEIR FAMILY
COULD BE THE LAST TIME THAT THEY
SAY GOODBYE.
WE WOULD JOIN IN HONORING ALL OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO HAS TAKEN
THE SAN TIMELY PASSING AND I TO
ADJOURN AND THE MEMORY OF
CORPORAL SING.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI.
SENATOR PANDA GERMAN A GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS --
I TODAY I RISE TO TURN MEMORY OF
FABRICS STRIVE FOR WHO PASSED
AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY ON JUNE FIRST.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN RICK WAS A
LOVING FATHER AND HUSBAND THE
CARING MANTIS FAMILY FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY.
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
THIRTY SIX YEARS JESSE DAUGHTERS
CHELSEY SHRIVER IMMERSE ALAN
CENTER LOS STUART ALLEN AND
GRANDDAUGHTER ANNABEL.
I'LL MANY OF THEM WHO ARE
JOINING US TODAY HERE IN THE
GALLERY --
RECALLS A TWENTY PLUS YEAR
MEMBER OF THE OAK GROVES LINES
CLUB WHERE HE HELD EVERY BOARD
POSITION.
AND WAS MOST RECENTLY A MEMBER
OF THE FORT CENTER LINES CLOTHES
SACRAMENTO.
HE COACHES DAUGHTERS AND SOCCER
SOFTBALL WAS ACTIVE.
AS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE ALWAYS WILLING TO A
RISK WITH RICK WAS AS BEST WHEN
HELPING OTHERS AND WILL BE
MISSED A BUYER TIRE COMMUNITY --
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF RICH DRIVER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR
DODD DID YOU HAVE IN A JOURNEY
MEMORY.
THANK YOU UP BETTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS PROFESSOR OF PROFESSOR
FLOYD F. FEENEY PASSED AWAY ON
TUESDAY JANUARY EIGHTH AT EIGHTY
FIVE YEARS OLD AFTER A SHORT
ILLNESS.
VOID WAS A LIFE LINE LIFELONG
TEACHER SCHOLAR AND PUBLIC
SERVANT.
FLAYED RECEIVED HIS
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE FROM
DAVIDSON COLLEGE IN HIS GED FROM
NEW YORK UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
LAW.
FLOYD ALSO --
WORK IN WASHINGTON DC BEFORE
COMING TO DAVIS HE WAS A LAW
CLERK FOR U. S. SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE HUGO BLACK DURING THE
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE TERM.
HE LATER SERVED AS DEPUTY
SPECIAL COUNSEL FOR THE
PRESIDENT KENNEDY'S COMMITTEE ON
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE AGENCY. FOR
INTERNATIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE
PRESIDENT'S CRIME COMMISSION.
INTERNATIONALLY AS A FULBRIGHT
SCHOLAR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
AUGSBURG GERMANY HE TAUGHT
LECTURED IN CHINA GERMANY.
ITALY JAPAN MEXICO AND THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
I FOUND EXACTLY MEMBER FLOYD
JOINED UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE YEAR
THE LAW SCHOOL BUILDING WAS
COMPLETE.
DECADES OF STUDENTS FROM CHIEF
JUSTICE DIED --
TADI CAN'T HEAL SAW TO WEIGH --
TO FORMER PRESS SENATE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM GERALD STEINBERG WERE
IMPACTED BY IS LEGENDARY
DEDICATION.
AND GENEROSITY HE TAUGHT AT UC
DAVIS SCHOOL WA FOR OVER FIFTY
YEARS AND REPRESENTED ALL THAT
WAS GREAT ABOUT MARTIN LUTHER%
KING JUNIOR HALL.
IS RESPECT FOR ALL HIS
COMMITMENT TO LAW SCHOOL HE WAS
SO CENTRAL.
IN CREATING WAY TO SURVIVE BY
HIS TWO DAUGHTERS IN MANY LOVED
ONES FRIENDS AND FORMER STUDENTS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOINING IN
MEMORY A PROFESSOR FLOYD FEENEY.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
ALAN.
MEMBERS IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS
THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF BAR
BRATTLE SENIOR SLUTSKY.
WHO WAS AN ICON A MENTOR AND
ACTIVISTS IN AN INSPIRATION WHO
I FEEL SO BLESSED TO HAVE?
CALLED A FRIEND.
HER UNEXPECTED AN UNTIMELY
PASSING JUST TWO WEEKS AGO SILL
SEEMS IMPOSSIBLE I EVERY TIME I
STEP ON A SOUTHWEST FLIGHT I
THINK AMINUTE --
SEE HER ON THE PLANE COMING UP
TO SACRAMENTO INOPPORTUNE TO
TALK WITH HER.
AS YOU SO FULL OF LIFE AND I I
THINK SO FULL OF LIFE AND WHEN I
HEARD THAT SHE'D BEEN RELEASED.
FROM CEDAR SINAI MEDICAL CENTER
ON DECEMBER TWENTY FIRST --
AFTER BATTLING AND APPARENTLY
BESTING A DEVASTATING ABOUT WEST
NILE VIRUS.
I ASSUME THAT SHE WAS
UNDOUBTEDLY ON THE MAN --
BUT IT TURNED OUT AS BECAUSE OF
A BLOOD CLOT ASSOCIATED WITH THE
WITH THE VIRUS --
FROM BEFORE SHE ENDED UP.
IN THERAPY AND THAT AND UP --
IN THE CITY FASTER TO BE BROUGHT
BACK TO THE HOSPITAL WHERE SHE
PASSED AWAY --
SHE WAS. THIRTY ONE YEARS OLD I
HER LIFE IS PACKED FULL OF
MILESTONES AND ACHIEVEMENTS.
TO LAST MANY LIFETIMES --
BUT HER SENSELESS IN SUDDEN
DEATH CAME SO FAST AND SO SOON
AND I WILL SAY MEMBERS --
THIS IS MADE ME ACUTELY AWARE OF
THIS.
RIDICULOUS AND DEVASTATING
DISEASE THAT IS.
RIGHT IN OUR IN OUR IN OUR MIDST
I'M SHE WAS BIT IN IS OUR
BACKYARD IN HANCOCK PARK IN LOS
ANGELES --
BY MISKITO THAT WAS --
CAME EARLY FROM NEXT DOOR WHERE
THERE WAS A AYE AND TENDED TO
COUSY THAT.
I HAD BECOME A BREEDING GROUND
FOR THESE MOSQUITOES.
AND NEXT THING YOU KNOW.
HE'S BEEN TAKEN FROM US.
BARBARA WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
LOS ANGELES SHE MET HER HUSBAND
SAYS I WHEN SHE WAS WORK WHEN HE
WAS WORKING AS A HALL MONITOR AT
LOS ANGELES HEBREW HIGH SCHOOL --
WHICH IS A A SUPPLEMENTAL JEWISH --
SCHOOL THAT THE KIDS GO --
TO AFTER THEY GO TO TO REGULAR
SCHOOL I'M I WENT THERE MYSELF
AND SHE WAS AT THE FRONT DESK.
STAFFING AT THE AMERICAN JEWISH
UNIVERSITY WHICH IS WHAT HOUSE
THE HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THEY WERE MARRIED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND THEY
RAISE TWO WONDERFUL CHILDREN
DAUGHTER NINA.
AND THEIR SON DAVID WHO IS JUST
TO THE TO THE BENCH.
BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
AS I WAS ELECTED TO THE LAWSUIT
THE CITY COUNCIL AND EVENTUALLY
TO THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND I HAD THE HONOR
OF SERVING --
AS AN INTERN ON HIS STAFF FOR
TWO SUMMERS.
THAT'S WHY I REALLY GOT TO KNOW
BARBARA WELL --
AND YET THROUGH IT ALL BARBER
WAS WAS BY HIS SIDE BUT VERY
MUCH A YOUNG TO IS ABSENT NâNG.
AND AND HAD A VERY DIFFERENT AND
A VERY EFFECTIVE PERSONALITY --
THAT WAS SO FULL OF KINDNESS AND
AND ENERGY AND AND AND AND AND
DETERMINATION.
SHE ALSO WAS VERY COMMITTED TO
JUDAISM OR JUNIOR JEWISH AND THE
BROADER JEWISH COMMUNITIES GOT
VERY INVOLVED WITH --
WITH NON PROFITS IN THAT
COMMUNITY SHE GOT VERY INVOLVED
WITH A WHOLE SLEW OF SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCIES AND IN BLOOD
INVOLVED WITH WITH SOME GROUPS
THAT THAT ADVANCE --
THE RIGHTS AND HEALTH OF WOMEN
AND FAMILIES AND CHILDREN NOT
THROUGHOUT I JUST ABOUT LOS
ANGELES BUT ALSO THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND MANY OF
YOU KNOW.
THAT SHE ENDED UP SAME SERVING
AS CHAIR OF OUR MEDICAL BOARD
FOR THIS BOARD THAT'S HOW I
ENDED UP GETTING TO SPEND A LOT
OF TIME WITH HER BECAUSE WE
WOULD.
SIT NEXT TO EACH OTHER ON THE
AIRPLANES OUT THERE THE THAT
SACRAMENTO SCHOOL BUS --
SOUTHWEST FLIGHTS FROM LOS
ANGELES AND WE WOULD SIT
TOGETHER BAD EVERY MONTH AND
JUST TALK SHOP AND AND THE GREAT
THING ABOUT BARBARA WAS THAT SHE
WAS ALWAYS SO INTERESTED
EVERYBODY ELSE YOU WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT MY LIFE MY FAMILY --
WHAT I WAS DOING AND AND SHE WAS
JUST A A WONDERFUL KIND MENTOR
AND?
YOU KNOW WHEN I FIRST HEARD THE
NEWS ABOUT HER DEATH MY WIFE AND
I WERE DRIVING FROM PITTSBURGH
INTO YOUNGSTOWN OHIO AND WE BOTH.
WE BOTH STARTED TO CRY IN THE
CAR.
HI MY WIFE RECOUNTED HOW
INCREDIBLY KIND BARBER HAD
ALWAYS BEEN TO HER EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
HI YES THEY SAY SHE HAD
BOUNDLESS HUMANITY AS SHE IS ONE
OF THE KINDEST SOULS THAT I'VE
EVER ENCOUNTERED --
BUT SHE ALSO HAD THIS FIERCE
LIMITLESS IMBUED THIRST FOR
JUSTICE.
AND CARED SO DEEPLY ABOUT OTHERS
AND I THINK THAT THAT WAS
REFLECTED IN THE TURN OUT AT HER
FUNERAL.
AT TEMPLE ISRAEL IN HOLLYWOOD
OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE PACKED
INTO THAT.
SANCTUARY MANY OF YOU ARE THERE
AS WELL AND NOW WE GOT TO HEAR
FROM -- FROM
FROM SO MANY SPEAKERS WHO SPOKE
WITH WITH SUCH.
WITH SUCH COMPASSION IN SUCH
PASSION ABOUT BARBARA AND HER
LIFE.
SO I JUST WANNA SAY AS A
HEARTBROKEN CONSTITUENT AND
FRIEND OF HERS THANK YOU BARBARA
WE'RE GOING TO MISS YOU SO MUCH.
AND THE BROADER LOS SANTOS
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE DEEPLY IN YOUR
DAD.
A THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT
TO ADD MY NOTE OF CONDOLENCE --
AS A ROOKIE IN [inaudible]
POLITICS.
A BARBER HAD A UNIQUE ABILITY TO
TO BUTTONHOLE YOU.
AND TELL YOU HOW IT REALLY WAS --
HER ABILITY TO BE UNVARNISHED.
WHO WAS A?
FEARS KIND OF LOVE THAT POLITICS
DOESN'T ALWAYS SEE BECAUSE WE
WERE POLITICS AND AND YOU YOU
LIKE.
TO PERHAPS CAN SEE --
WHAT YOU REALLY MEAN SOMETIMES
TO TO SAVE PEOPLE?
FROM FROM UNCOMFORTABLE MOMENTS
BUT BARBARA DIDN'T HAVE TIME FOR
THAT.
BECAUSE SHE WAS ON A MISSION.
AND SHE WAS ON A MISSION FOR
PEOPLE.
ZEV GAVE OF A VERY TOUGH AND AND
HUGE EULOGY FOR HIS.
WIFE AND HE SAID HER PAST TIME
WAS PEOPLE.
THEY MET WHEN SHE WAS ACTUALLY
RUNNING THE SWITCHBOARD --
AND HE WAS THE MESSENGER BOY --
BACK IN --
BACK IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN THEY
HAD SWITCHBOARDS.
I THOUGHT ABOUT THAT SWITCHBOARD
OPERATION I'M JUST CONNECTING
THIS PERSON TO THIS PERSON.
RIGHT YOU HAVE TO MAKE THE CALL
AND HOW DO YOU MAKE THAT
CONNECTION --
THAT WAS HER FOR THE REST OF HER.
WAS MATCH MAKING IN MARRIAGES.
WAS FINDING WAYS TO CONNECT.
DOCTORS WHO WERE IMMIGRANTS TO
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED THE HELP THE
FAST THE FAST TRACK THEM THROUGH
THE LICENSING PROCESS BUT REALLY
BECAUSE PEOPLE NEED TO CONNECT
WITH PEOPLE.
SO SHE WAS STOLEN FROM US
[inaudible]
BUT THAT LIGHTS NOT OUT.
AND THAT BILL CAMPION WRONG AND
BARBER WILL CONTINUE TO BE WITH
US -- THE IN
THAT SPIRIT AND AND THAT
UNVARNISHED --
LOVE THAT --
WE MISS ALL TOO MUCH SO HUMBLY
JOINING HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN CENTER
HERTZBERG.
LIKE TO BRIEFLY JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE JOURNEYING IN.
ARE WE ARE SLUSH HE'S MEMORY YOU
KNOW EACH OF US HERE ON THE
FLOOR OF HAD.
RICH LIVES IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
AND WE'VE ALL HAD OPPORTUNITIES
IN OUR LIVES TO MEET PEOPLE THAT
HAVE INSPIRED US.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE IMPACTED US I
HAVE KNOWN BARBARA FOR DECADES
AND AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER SHE
WAS INDEED THE YANG TO
SUPERVISOR YAROSLAVSKY JIANG IN
THE MOST.
SIGNIFICANT WAY.
AND I JUST WITHOUT BEING
REDUNDANT BUT A COUPLE OF ISSUES
YOU KNOW NUMBER ONE IS SERVICE.
AT EVERY LEVEL OF WHAT THAT WORD
MEANT IN HER LIFE OFTEN SOMEONE
IS A PARTNER TO A PUBLIC PERSON.
A YOU KNOW WITH THERE'S A WHOLE
BUNCH OF CHALLENGES BUT SHE IN
HER OWN RIGHT BE ON THE BOARD
SHE SAT ON EVERYTHING THAT SHE
DID.
IN THE COMMUNITY WHEN SHE BEFORE
SHE PASSED HAD A SERIOUS
ACCIDENT BECAUSE SHE WAS
STRIPPED ON A STEP IF YOU WANT
TO SOMEONE'S HOUSE TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM.
BECAUSE SOMEONE HAD PASSED AWAY
AND SHE WAS TAKING CARE OF THE
FAMILY THE STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO
SHE BRING GIFTS TO AND SHE WOULD
CALL THE GIFTS NOT BECAUSE THEY
WERE THE BIRTHDAYS OF THE
HOLIDAYS.
SHE CALLED IN JUST BECAUSE GIFTS
BECAUSE SHE THOUGHT ABOUT
SOMEONE AND TOOK CARE OF HIM IN
SO MANY WAYS ALL ACROSS THE
COMMUNITIES NOT JUST IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITY ALTHOUGH JUDAISM WAS
SO IMPORTANT TO HER.
AND I THINK THAT --
SO IT REALLY IS ABOUT SERVICE OR
CHARACTER IT I I WAS WITH HER SO
MANY TIMES IN SO MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES AND OFTEN WE SEE A
PUBLIC FACE OF PEOPLE AND WE SEE
A DIFFERENT FACE.
IN PRIVATE THAT WEOFTEN HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE AND THAT
WASN'T THE CASE WITH BARBARA
YAROSLAVSKY AND LASTLY THE
UNIQUE PARTNERSHIP THAT THEY HAD.
A IN THE YING AND YANG THEY
REALLY WERE TRUE PARTNERS
ADDRESS LOSSKY WAS A DYNAMIC
FORCE FOR DECADES IN THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IN
SO MANY AREAS.
OF PUBLIC POLICY BUT I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT BARBARA YAROSLAVSKY
WAS AN EQUAL PARTNER IN EVERY
ASPECT OF THAT WORD AND I JOIN
IN.
THE MEMORY IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT OF THAT.
MISKITO MY BROTHER TOLD ME USED
TO WORK FOR GORE FACES A SECOND
CASE IN THE LA COUNTY --
MUSKEGO --
MUSKEGO IT REALLY IS THE POINT
THAT YOU MADE ABOUT YOU KNOW
JUST WEST OF OUR DIAL THING WE
CAN THINK ABOUT BUT HERE IT IS
OUR OWN BACKYARD TO SOMEONE WHO
WE DEARLY LOVE.
ADJOURNING OR MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTER JACKSON IS VERY BRIEFLY I
FEEL AS OF THAT THE THERE NEED
TO BE A WOMAN'S VOICE TO THIS
BECAUSE BARBARA --
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT --
WOMEN NEEDED TO STAND UP AND
SPEAK OUT AND I HAD THE HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING BARBARA
SHE WAS VERY ACTIVE IN HADASSAH.
AND AS SOON AS SHE HEARD THAT MY
MOTHER HAD BEEN A LIFE TIME
MEMBER OF HADASSAH WE BECAME
LIFETIME FRIENDS.
AND I THINK THAT SORT OF THE
PICS THIS WAS LOVE LIFE LOVE
PEOPLE LOVE TRYING TO FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY FOR
EVERYONE.
AND SO I WANT TO JOIN MY MALE
COLLEAGUES BARBARA YOUR VOICE
WAS HEARD.
INSPIRED ME TO GET UP ON BEHALF
OF THE WOMEN OF OUR COMMUNITY
THE WOMEN OF THE STATE.
THE JEWISH WOMEN OF HADASSAH AND
ALL THE OTHER GROUPS THAT --
SHE WAS A KEY FORCE IN PROMOTING
AND INCENTIVIZING AND LOVING.
A WARM EMBRACE TO BARBARA WE
WILL MISS YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
PORTANTINO'S YOU'VE BEEN INJURED
IN MEMORY.
YES SIR THANK YOUR COLLEAGUE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
THERE'S VERY FEW ICONIC
ENTERTAINMENT SYMBOLS IN
AMERICAN POP CULTURE AND ONE OF
THEM IS SPONGE BOB SQUARE PANTS.
AND SO TODAY I ASK YOU I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF STEPHEN
HILLENBURG --
WHO WAS A YOUNG MAN OF FIFTY
SEVEN HE WAS MY AGE --
AFTER HIS BATTLE WITH ALS
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS LOU
GEHRIG'S DISEASE STEVEN IS KNOWN
AS THE CREATOR IN DEVELOPING THE
NICKELODEON CARTOON SERIES
SPONGE BOB SQUARE PANTS.
WHICH IS BROUGHT JOY TO
GENERATIONS OF KIDS AND FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD MISTER
CALIBER GRADUATED FROM HUMBOLDT
STATE UNIVERSITY IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE.
IN NATURAL RESOURCE PLANNING AN
INTERPRETATION QUICKLY AFTER
COLLEGE HE BECAME A MARINE
BIOLOGY TEACHER IN THE ORANGE
COUNTY MARINE INSTITUTE IN DANA
POINT CALIFORNIA.
HE THEN WENT ON SKEWS ME.
HE THEN WENT ON TO BEGAN AS IT
ANIMATION CURRENT NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PURSUING A DEGREE
IN EXPERIMENTAL ANIMATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF THE ARTS.
IN VALENCIA EARNING HIS MASTER'S
IN FINE ARTS IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO HE COVERED THE ENTIRE STATE
WITH HIS FORMATIVE YEARS AND HIS
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT.
FROM NINETEEN NINETY THREE TO
NINETEEN NINETY SIX HE WAS A
WRITER AND DIRECTOR ON THE
NICKELODEON SERIES ROCKO'S
MODERN LIFE WHERE HE WORKED WITH
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD
THEN HELP HIM DEVELOP.
SPONGEBOB THE FIRST EPISODE ON
MAY FIRST NINETEEN NINETY NINE
AND THE SERIES HAS AIRED NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY EPISODES
TO DATE.
IT APPEAL NOT ONLY TO CHILDREN
BUT TO OLDER VIEWERS AS WELL
WITH COLLEGE STUDENTS EVEN
ORGANIZING.
VIEWING PARTIES FOR THE SHOW THE
SERIES IS ONE BOTH U. S. AND
BRITISH EMMY AWARDS ANY AWARDS
AN A. S. A. C. P. AWARDS AND HAS
BEEN DUBBED OR SUBTITLED INTO
MORE.
THAN SIXTY DIFFERENT LANGUAGES --
STEVEN ELLENBERGER SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE KAREN.
SON CLAY HIS MOTHER NANCY AND
BROTHER BRIAN.
HE WAS JUST SUCH A NICE
UNASSUMING MAN HIS WIFE.
I WAS VERY ACTIVE IN OUR LOCAL
PLANNED PARENTHOOD CHAPTER THEY
WERE JUST QUIET NICE PEOPLE WHO
GAVE BACK TO THE COMMUNITY AND
YOU WOULD HAVE NEVER THOUGHT.
HE WAS A HOLLYWOOD ANIMATOR WHEN
YOU MET HIM HE WAS JUST WOULD
YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT HE WAS A
GUY NEXT DOOR WHO'S JUST A NICE.
KIND UNASSUMING MAN WHO BROUGHT
LAUGHS ENJOY TWO GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION THE
SPONGE BOB HE INTRODUCED US TO
PATRICK.
SQUIDWARD MR KRABS PLANKTON GARY
SCHOOL WILLIAM AND WE ARE ALL
BETTER OFF FOR HIS CREATIVITY
AND AS LEGACY IN MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE HILLENBURG
FAMILY THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
JOIN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE ANOTHER.
ADJOURNMENT READ THAT YOU WANT
TO WAIT ON BUT YOU ARE THE LAST
ONE SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO THAT
AMER ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRO TEM AND
MEMBERS --
AGAIN I RISE --
TO ASHY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE DARRYL
TILLMAN GANT.
DOWN DARRYL PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY AT HOME ON SURROUNDED
BY HIS LOVING FAMILY DAR WAS
BORN ON NOVEMBER FOURTH
FOURTEENTH. NINETEEN NINETY
THREE TO MAGGIE PEARL AND FOUND
TILLMAN GANT IN THE COUNTRY TOWN
OF BLAIR OKLAHOMA HE GRADUATED
FROM DIE NUBA HIGH SCHOOL AND I
KNEW A CALIFORNIA.
AND RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS HIS
MBA FROM UCLA.
HE THEN ENTERED THE ARMY AND WAS
STATIONED AT FORT LEE IN
VIRGINIA WHERE HE MET HIS
BELOVED WIFE MARY WEST.
DARYL AND MARY WERE MARRIED
AFTER JUST THREE MONTHS AND
REMAINED MARRIED FOR SIXTY TWO
YEARS.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THE GAPS
MOVED WITH THEIR INFANT DAUGHTER
BRENDA LE WE USED TO LOCK OR SET
A CALIFORNIA.
WHERE THEIR SECOND DAUGHTER
TRACY WAS BORN THREE YEARS LATER?
DARYL JOINED JET PROPULSION
LABORATORY IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
AS A SENIOR CONTRACT NEGOTIATOR
WHERE HE REMAINED UNTIL HE
RETIRED IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BUSINESS AFFAIRS.
HE RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS FOR
HIS OUTSTANDING WORK FROM BOTH
GPL AT NASA.
AFTER HIS RETIREMENT HE AND MARY
TRAVELED EXTENSIVELY AND BECAME
ACTIVE COMMUNITY VOLUNTEERS
GIVING BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITY
IN MANY CAPACITIES.
DARRYL WAS A SPECIALLY INVOLVED
IN THE QANTAS CLUB OF LOCKING
OUT OF WHICH IS WHERE I FIRST
MET HIMAS A QUAN YIN MEMBER F
THAT CLUB.
THE LOCKING OUT OF FLINT RIDGE
TOURNAMENT OF ROSES AND A
LOCKING OUT OF FORT RIDGE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION.
THIS YEAR'S FLOAT WON ANOTHER
AWARD AND DARYL AND MARY WERE
CENTRAL TO THE VOLUNTEER EFFORT
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
DARRYL CHERISH THE FRIENDSHIPS
THAT HE MADE HE TRULY LOVED HIS
FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITY HE WAS
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO WOULD
COME UP TO YOU AND ASK YOU.
NOT JUST THE PERFUNCTORY.
OBLIGA TORY QUESTION ABOUT HOW
LIFE IS BUT TO GENERALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
YOUR LIFE WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
THE STATE AND JUST ONE OF THOSE
RARE.
NICE GENTLEMAN PEOPLE THAT WE
ALL LONG TO SEE MORE OF IN OUR
GREAT STATE AND I ASKED YOU TO
RESPECTFULLY OFFER OUR
CONDOLENCES AND ADJOURNMENTS
MEMBERS OF THANK.
YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO MEMBERS
OTHER ANY FURTHER A JOURNEY
MEMORIES.
SEEING NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR JANUARY
SEVENTH THROUGH TENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR WILK THE DESK
IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT --
TO CONGRATULATE THE MEMBERS FOR
VERY HISTORIC A PRODUCTIVE WEEK
I HOPE YOU GET TO GO HOME WE HAD
A GREAT TIME WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY TODAY WHICH
TIME THE AGE ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE AND WE WILL
RECONVENE HERE AT TWO PM ON
MONDAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE
A GREAT WEEKEND.
THANK SENATOR WILK THIS AND
WE'LL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM HAVE A GREAT DAY EVERYONE